so I have been here as a respiratory
consultant in this ward in the hospital
for 24 years and I've never ever seen it
anything like this before
professor
guided his team and his patience through
the pandemic
but this winter he says is the worst
he's ever seen you've got Kobe you've
got influenza patients you've got covet
again after that
the triple demek of flu covered and a e
pressures make already difficult
conditions even harder
hello John
you okay
John is 92 he lives by himself his wife
is in a nursing home when I was young I
felt the way they talk people are gonna
healthy and healthier yeah hospitals all
very quiet as much and it's just kind of
the opposite
on Sunday he woke up in the early hours
barely able to move with flu
his son rushed him to hospital the
ambulance would have taken two hours
when I came in I couldn't take a drink I
couldn't do anything
and I'm getting slightly stronger every
day
I couldn't even use my mobile phone I
still feel very weak how much of a bed
bath this morning I said can you do
yourself
Professor manava thinks John like many
other patients in his care only survived
because they were vaccinated this winter
on this Ward every bed in every Bay is
full and as soon as one is empty it's
taken up again by a waiting patient it's
been like this since the beginning of
December and it could last all the way
through
until May
and that could impact work being done to
reduce the backlog of patience on the
waiting list already with the two to
three year backlog that has developed
thanks to covet the entire pandemic
we were trying to play catch-up we were
trying to clear some of that backlog now
this will set us back again
more people attended a e in December
than ever before and they're waiting
longer to be admitted and treated star
from the front line are struggling to
cope with the demand we know about
burnouts in the NHS how long can your
staff sustain and work in the sustained
pressure a lot of colleagues who have
been working full-time they've had to
reduce the errors they do just to
maintain their own well-being so if
we're not careful we'll make it such an
unattractive place to work that we won't
have anyone coming through to care for
us when we're in crisis in Needham how
are you feeling today yes it's gone very
well the pressure builds throughout the
system
here at the Royal Preston Hospital
they're working hard to protect their
cancer services and then just let me
know when you're ready
Anita was diagnosed with breast cancer
in July she's the first patient here to
receive surface-guided radiotherapy
new technology making treatment more
accurate and more effective it allows
the hospital to treat more patients when
I was diagnosed with cancer it was it's
a bombshell because I at work I'm active
I didn't find any lumps or anything I
feel so blessed that I've been able to
do this journey and come to this stage
[Music]
four Anita this Bell celebrates the end
of her treatment Journal but many others
are still waiting to start theirs
oh she's Josh is Sky News in Preston